all right how about this for mom forget  those edible arrangements  chocolate fruit you don't need them how  about this moms maybe really want this  fried chicken bouquet this is the  kentucky fried  bucket get it it's a partnership between  kfc and pro flowers features a fried  chicken skewered and tucked into a vase  alongside the roses but here's the deal  okay you got to pay attention to this to  get one first you need to order a kfc  sides lovers meal either today or  tomorrow  then you get a promo code to redeem that  bucket kit from pro flowers and that  includes the vase that includes the  roses and eight skewers but you have to  buy the chicken separately you have to  redeem the kit by thursday in order to  get it that's a lot to digest i know i'm  sure it's on their website check it out  if you want the chicken so